bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i have the man
himself he is back jim what's going on
man
here's what's going on you made me a ton
of money and
i i had to keep out the excellence there
because when someone's made me as much
money as you have you do want to
kind of pepper it with the authentic
language i did exactly what you told me
now i know you probably hear a lot of
people say you know what i did what you
told me
no i went and called my cfo all right
and i said listen i just talked to this
guy and
i went tomorrow and i'm gonna give you
some numbers i said i won
i hope i don't get in trouble i said i
want a half million dollars
in this and you can buy it over a couple
of days but i don't want any longer than
that
because this guy was the authentic deal
and i had studied it before it wasn't
like i just like you know
i didn't just fall off the turnip truck
but i said this guy is compelling i even
used and i don't know whether you have
any philosophy
the brokerage you suggested and um i
i mentioned the money because it's never
happened to me before i've bought a lot
of stocks in my life
but i want to thank you somebody the
reason i called jason can i please come
on your show and thank you
because it happened it happened just as
you said
it also happened much faster than you
said but i'm very grateful and you know
what else is grateful
my kids so thank you very much well
listen as
as many people who watched our first
episode together i think noted
uh the most compelling piece of it was
how open-minded you were
and uh and how intellectually curious
you are and i think that is something
that uh
people forget is important in the uh
investing world so
i can yell and scream from uh from the
rooftop all i want but it takes uh
courage and conviction for you to do
something about it so well
it comes from studying your work uh and
look by the way i mean you can say well
i'm sucking up i'm not a sucker i mean i
just had tremendous respect
uh a lot of what you said to me i have
since of course told others
and and we're not you know there are
things that you would say i mean i
always do that there was a limited
number of bitcoin
uh i always knew that there should be
protection and i regard it as an asset
class
uh but i have so i have for years said
that you should have gold
and i think that what i had going for me
was the recognition
that what you were saying is what i was
really
searching for with gold all along but
gold let me down
gold is subject to too many vicissitudes
it's subject to uh mining issues
it's frankly uh subject to uh
failing in many cases where do you think
that's what's gonna happen do you think
that people are gonna drop gold and buy
bitcoin or what do you think's gonna
happen now
if they listen to me they're gonna drop
half their gold i've been saying 10
percent of gold
since 1983 and now i say five percent of
gold
five percent bitcoin and i did not say
that before i talked with you
i had thoroughly researched it i was
skeptical and the reason i was skeptical
was frankly because i said
you know what i've done okay with my
gold you know this is the old dog new
tricks thing that i won
i run up against was saying with the web
with the wall street bets people
like they're constantly saying oh listen
you know your old baby boomer you've
forgotten
i think it has to do with how young your
mind is and i listened to you
a friend of mine uh kieran goodwin said
i heard you on punk
pomp's the smartest guy i said you know
what damn straight
uh and i think that what matters isn't
how old you are it's whether you're
young enough
in hearing someone who knows more than
you and you know what a lot of what you
have to do is accept the fact that
someone knows more than you now we did
in school
it's very funny because you walk into a
chemistry class and you knew there were
guys who were geniuses in chemistry
you're gonna get blown out
i woke into a bitcoin class what do i
think i'm going to know more than the
bitcoin guy it's no different from a
chemistry class
no different from an engineering class i
walked into the pom class
and when i got not schooled but taught
by pomp i said
what am i doing not protecting myself
in what i've been saying to people could
be hyperinflation but even if there's
just
plain old inflation why not get in and i
did the thing like that the only thing i
was confused about
was was this notion you got to help me
here
currency versus asset class because i
think that i
am conf i'm conflicted and i and i'm
conflating
you can help me say what it really is
yeah so i think that there's three
things people are using it for right now
right so you have people who are using
it as a medium of exchange
people are using a store of value and
people are using it as a speculative
asset
right and those three things uh serve
different use cases for different people
um but i think that a currency obviously
medium of exchange is store of value
uh it's hard to deny that people are
storing value i think that's pretty well
accepted kind of the digital gold
narrative
um and then when you look at like
on-chain transaction volume right and
some days now
it's you know 10 12 15 billion dollars
in a single 24 hour period of this
transaction volume
that's putting it into trillions of
dollars on an annualized basis which
you know visa and some of these guys are
i don't know eight to 12 trillion
dollars in annualized volume
so you're talking about maybe 25 to 50
percent
of the largest card networks in the
world uh so people are using it now what
they're using it for
is very hard to determine but they're
using as some sort of medium of exchange
and then i think the third one and
probably the one that everyone focuses
on
is the speculative nature right people
are absolutely in some cases buying it
because they think it's going to go up
in u.s dollar terms and they're going to
sell it at a profit later
um and so i think that what we got to
figure out here is what's the dominant
use case
are most people speculating or are most
people using it to store value or most
people using it at a medium of exchange
my guess is when you look at the data 60
of bitcoin hasn't moved in the last 12
months
so that tells me that the majority is
being used as a store of value over
everything else today
now what happens in the future we'll
find out but that's how i kind of think
about you know from a use case
perspective and
is it a currency is it an asset well
technically it could be both
right right well you know for me
because of my my bag here's something
that is old dog
i have always said to people listen if
you could ever ever ever be in a
situation
where you can play with the house's
money you take out what you put in
then uh you're blessed and you never
have to touch it and that's what i've
done there a lot of people may have only
took out that took out the money i put
in
but now i've been i'm never going to
touch it pump
i'm not and i may never because
you traced out a scenario for those of
us who i if those of you who haven't
watched it
you twist out a scenario that doesn't
stop at a hundred thousand and
a lot of people laugh and i didn't it
was at twelve thousand
and i started thinking i gotta get in
before it got to fifty and i went home
and told my wife i said lisa i'm doing
this thing
and she said why and i described it or
skype our talk is just
you sound mesmerized i said no i i sound
educated
these are two different things it's not
being mesmerized it was educated
and the course that you laid out made me
think you know what it isn't just a
current i bought it as currency
but i realized it was a store of value
and a better store value of what i was
using
and did i have the belief that it could
grow up though i mean i i did believe
that it could be speculative
staying power but more importantly what
i realized is
uh i deal a lot with a company square
and
instead of saying that you know that i'm
gonna ride the speculation wave
i knew that that's this cash app people
kids are buying
uh they're buying you know a little bit
of schnitzel
they're buying uh slivers of bitcoin and
i said to myself
you know what i want to be with them
because they represent the future
but i also recognize they may be doing
it for whatever reason but i can be part
of that wave too and not feel that that
wave is
is um uh flawless it's not
thoughtless speculation not after the
way that you late
you know you laid it out and i am sure
that you can lay it out
for just in one minute you gotta just
lay it out again i know that's a short
capsule
probably not fair but why you know
exactly what made me pull the trick
yeah i mean look it's very simple
there's a fixed supply asset and if
demand increases the us dollar price
value has to go up
and what we're seeing now is
historically there was tons of retail
investors that were coming in with
retail dollars
but now every single financial
institution and corporation
are asking the question what is our
bitcoin strategy and when they show up
tesla shows up with a billion and a half
dollars michael saylor shows up with a
billion dollars you know
uh jp morgan guggenheim hundreds of
millions of dollars and so i think that
naturally what you're going to just see
is continued upward price movement
to accommodate everyone because the
existing holders don't want to sell
and so you know again 100k i think is a
milestone
on a a much longer journey where it goes
and on what time frame who knows
but uh i i think that it's pretty crazy
that you know just a couple of months
ago was 12k and now we're sitting here
and it's you know 55
60 000 whatever it is so you know kudos
to you
what questions do you have let's
i suggested that corporate treasurers
which i
one time handled a 100 million dollar
fund for a corporation
that corporate treasurers should put a
percentage
of their corporate cash
into bitcoin and i was laughed at
universally should i have been no
of course not and what you're going to
find is most corporate treasurers i
think pride themselves
on uh the fact that they're not running
a hedge fund right they don't want to
look at themselves as speculative
investors
um but ultimately what their job is more
than anything
is risk mitigation right so everyone
thinks of bitcoin and they look at the
upside oh how much could it go up in us
dollar value
but actually if you look at it the other
way right and we could talk about some
of the kind of inflation concerns that
probably you and i both have
it you start to say wait a second the
dollar actually may be the riskier asset
out of these two
uh if you look at your bond portfolio
there's not a lot of bonds you can hold
right now they're going to really retain
value in the same way and so
i just say to people look zoom all the
way out look at a 10-year track record
right
bitcoin has grown in us dollar terms at
a 200
compound annual growth rate 200 a year
for 10 years right 12 years whatever
it's been
and you can say all that you want in
terms of oh that's because it started
out really small and you know there was
no exchanges or whatever and it grew
well the compound annual growth rate
over the last 10 years has been going
up this year right it started out the
year like 196 percent
and now it's at like 205 and so
naturally like you're just getting this
upward movement and so
i think that ultimately what you're
starting to see whether it's
microstrategy square
tesla etc is absolutely the founders or
the ceos of these businesses
happen to be uh individuals who are
forward thinking who are technology kind
of uh
minded uh and they see that they're not
gonna go put 50
but they're gonna put a percentage
whether that's one percent uh
up to you know tesla i think it's got
seven eight percent uh michael saylor
from microstrategy is taking a very
different approach he's saying listen
i'm going to get the uh market to give
me
free dollars right at zero percent
interest rates and i'm gonna take that
as free dollars that are guaranteed to
lose value over time
i'm gonna convert it to this sound money
it's digital sound money
and i think that what we're about to see
and again i don't know exact timing i
don't know who kind of will break the
damn
uh even further but i think we're about
to see a lot of people do this
why would you not take free money that
you can then go convert to sound money
and essentially watch it continue to
appreciate and so i think that
um what this is going to happen is this
is going to go from on
wall street what was a contrarian idea
has now transitioned to a consensus idea
everyone has a bitcoin strategy or is
trying to figure out what it is
in corporate america with the treasurers
what you're about to see is
we're probably on the precipice of the
transition from contrarian idea to
consensus idea
and when that happens they're going to
bring a lot of dollars with them
right and so i think that you're just
going to continue to see this super
aggressive upwards price movement
uh over some period of time maybe it's
three months six months nine months
who knows what it is i'm sure that there
will be a blow off top at some point you
know kind of q4
this year q1 next year whatever but the
key that
uh point is going to be bitcoin's not
going to die it's not going to go to
zero right it's not a you know ponzi
scheme a bubble in the sense that
it's going to pop and go to zero instead
what you're going to see is you're going
to see the consolidation again some new
floor of
of the value of the asset and then we're
going to go through it all over again
because in 2024 we got another having
another supply shot coming
and so it's just this like crazy
beautifully designed
asset that i think now you're starting
to see wall street you're starting to
see corporations wake up to
and here's the crazy part that you'll
understand that some other listeners may
not
is bitcoin's probably the only asset
that
as it goes up in price it actually
becomes
more attractive to the corporations
because now it's getting to be big
enough where they can actually play in
it
and that's a wild concept right because
most assets the exact opposite
yes that's true and i think that there's
a great miscommunication there's a
there's another disservice being done to
bitcoin
which is that we hear that the
speculative juices got it say from 15
to 50. well how about that i could say
no see when the treasury prints 4
trillion that it doesn't have
that gets it from 15 to 50. i would bank
on my reasoning
as much as the speculator when you put
four trillion
and and when they're gonna make it back
with a one percent wealth tax
i mean are you kidding me i think that
there is no coincidence between
the amount of money that we're printing
and the and and this run
and therefore i don't think the run is
over because we're obviously
going to have to print to to pay for all
the prison
and every time you print to pay for the
printing it makes bitcoin worth more
of course it is the check uh
to undisciplined uh monetary policy what
let's talk a little bit about inflation
right so
uh there's now six trillion dollars uh
in quantitative easing that's occurred
we've seen
massive um kind of uh lowering of the
interest rates to emergency cuts last
year to a zero rate environment
uh there's plenty of people who say hey
we're in a deflationary environment
there's plenty of people who say well
the demand can soak up all
the printing uh at the counter argument
would be well food prices are going up
gas prices are going up lumber prices
are going up
um what's your take like is there
inflation are the official numbers
accurate how should we think about it
well i think that there's um there's two
kinds of inflation obviously there's the
inflation that
of the food variety of which i think
will be taken care of and the steel
variety will be taken care of
and then there's just the um
you can borrow money
for so little uh if you have a decent
balance sheet
only if you have decent balance sheet
and go buy
things of great value that you're going
to keep doing that and that inflation
is very much in place so i mean one of
the things that i've been doing my wife
is in real estate i'm not
doing stocks so she said look they're
giving the money away
let's just go by and i think that that
is for people who have fortunately have
been lucky enough to
do well they've given the money away
let's go buy is the inflation that's
gotta end
and that's what the fed is going to be
faced with i mean at what point does j
pal say you know what i can't continue
to have people makes you know have a
percentage of the people who are wealthy
make even more money as i struggle to
get the guys making 15
an hour to 18 an hour we need structural
change
i mean i'm not talking about whether you
know whether you're marxist or trottier
or whether you're a reaganist or
trump or whatever but that that kind of
inflation where you're still you're
paying
three percent uh interest rates for
something
that is a tremendous story of value like
i think land is or tremendous store
value like i think
uh that i think bitcoin is that's
inflationary and that's the kind of
inflation that i think
makes me want to talk to you because
it's inflation that i can
i can do something about i can't i can't
change
the price of point uh i can't change
even if world goes to four debbie gaston
goes to four
but i have to take protection i have to
defend
and there are some people who defend by
buying masterworks
i don't have the the hundred billion
million dollars to buy a special
painting
i think that does preserve its value i
know that in zimbabwe
certain mansions and huge amounts of
land
uh preserved value in weimar germany
gold preserved some value and united
states bitcoin preserves that
that's uh that's what you've taught me
and i i am happy to learn
i think the craziest part about this is
um
what we're essentially watching is a
real life economics course right where
people are understanding that
first everyone doesn't experience the
same level of inflation the bottom
socioeconomic statuses
experience higher levels of inflation
than the top and they also experience
different types of inflation
so the benefit accrues to the top in
terms of asset inflation right literally
the stock market gold
bitcoin real estate all that's going
through the roof uh at the same time
the cost of goods that is the majority
of expenses for the low associate
economic classes is also skyrocketing
and so one is a very consumption driven
type
financial situation the other is a very
investing heavy and so i keep going back
to this idea of the system is working
exactly as designed right the system's
not designed to make
a wealth inequality gap what it's
designed to do is to devalue a currency
slowly over time
in order to you know uh drum up economic
activity uh or investment
the problem is that only 55 of americans
understand that and are educated
uh on that information and so there's 55
of americans who hold investable assets
the bottom 45 hold no investable assets
right and so that's where you get that
bifurcation that continued kind of
um you know uh widening of the wealth
inequality gap and so to me it's a
financial education thing if we could
educate everybody and tell them hey
invest don't try to save your way to you
know some sort of financial freedom but
you have to invest
i think we could actually put a debt in
the problem it's just how do you do that
in an
efficient way how do you do it look i i
look obviously i'm not
denigrating the asset that i talk about
all the time which is stocks i am
saying that i can't earn individual
stocks so when something stumble it
comes along my way that i think you have
some appreciation
uh and it's it's not a stock it's pretty
fascinating which it's been real estate
and it's been what you talk about
i still think stocks are tremendous
investments by no means
by what we're talking about am i saying
and that's why i say you gotta
sell this that bit we have tremendous
stocks they've created amazing wealth
but i think that uh where i've got to go
next with you
is i'm on a conference call for nvidia
which is a stock that i've recommended
since it was it
about 10 bucks it's at 500. and one of
the things that happened in 2018 was
that people
used their cards to mine on the
conference call they talked about how
in march they're going to produce cards
that are just for ethereum mining so the
two questions i have is
one there are cards obviously these are
not swappable you don't just say i'll do
ethereum i'll do uh bitcoin
and two why is it in the interest of an
nvidia to
do that and who's buying it yeah
so there's a couple of questions in
there first is uh there's a specialized
type of computer
uh it's basically asic miner um that is
specifically focused on bitcoin mining
uh what the uh ethereum network and
other networks will use
is a a gpu right the graphic processing
units and so
um what you can do is there is some
level of variability in terms of you
have a gpu based uh minor
you could basically switch between a
handful of these different gpu based uh
type mining protocols uh but bitcoin
requires these asics and so
uh that tends to be kind of where you
get the difference uh and these
businesses are set up to do the gpus
right that kind of holy grail eventually
is going to be that somebody sets up an
advanced computing system
uh or a center and what they say is hey
i don't care if i'm doing
3d uh rendering i don't care if i'm
doing some sort of computation for
self-driving cars mining
uh some sort of cryptocurrency whatever
it is i just do advanced computing and i
have
one set of hardware and i can kind of do
all of it
i don't know how quick that's going to
happen but when we get to that world
then when it becomes really interesting
is then you get a real free market
dynamic at play that's going to push the
price of a lot of the
other types of advanced computing needs
down
and when you start to all of a sudden
say hey we can now do 3d rendering or we
can do stuff for self-driving cars or
other types of
dna sequencing or whatever and we can
push those costs down and lower the
friction
imagine all the innovation kind of
breakthroughs we're going to have when
you just
lower the cost to actually do some of
this stuff and so i think that's like a
big piece of it
nvidia and others like it i think are in
a really good spot because they
understand hardware software and
advanced computing and so
when you look at the bitcoin mining
businesses they got to do bitcoin mining
right that there's no ability for them
to kind of go into the other fields and
so i think that's really where you're
seeing a separation between the two
different types of hardware
really dictate kind of what you can do
with that hardware well i mean should i
be buying ethereum
look i think that there's a lot of folks
who basically look at ethereum in a
couple of different ways so first is
it's important to understand ethereum
and bitcoin are going after two
completely different things right
uh bitcoin is going after uh kind of the
world reserve currency right it wants to
disrupt gold it wants to disrupt central
banks and it wants to be this
programmatic transparent
monetary policy and uh my opinion and
many people in the bitcoin community is
that it's going to achieve that goal
right and so you can put whatever kind
of percentage uh
probability on that but that's kind of
what bitcoin's going after uh
ethereum basically was created by a
vitalik buterin and a few other folks
they wanted to build on top of the
bitcoin network
but they said hey this is too difficult
and so we need to go build
uh on something else that has smart
contract capabilities etc
and so now we've ended up in this world
where ethereum the network was built and
there's all kinds of people building
uh applications and various products and
services on top of that network
but also we now have a lot of uh smart
contract capabilities on top of bitcoin
and other networks as well and so what
you're going to end up seeing
is probably coexistence in this world
right a lot of people
they want to think that the world's
binary they want to say hey there's
going to be one thing to rule everything
but ultimately what we're seeing is
we're seeing the market adopt certain
things on the bitcoin network
uh in layer 2 technologies and smart
contract type uh capabilities
but also we're seeing that happen uh in
a very big way on ethereum
and then what i think is a really
interesting area is like what happens if
it's just interoperable
so if you're on the ethereum network on
the bitcoin network and we can actually
transact with each other in some
you know interesting way i don't know
where it goes i'm not a developer in
terms of having
the technical knowledge to say you know
hey here's the exact technology that's
going to be the winner
but i do think that uh the most
interesting part for investors is look
there's a ton of innovation and
experimentation happening
all across this ecosystem and the flood
of intellectual capital coming into this
from the world's best technologists is
undeniable
and such as you you just got to be in
the space right you got to have the
exposure and you got to start paying
attention
you know i it's funny i i posited uh on
one of these days when this game stopped
went to 350 that
you look i know that uh nvidia's going
to sell the gpus for ethereum
you know maybe gamestop should be in the
business of selling those
those cards but you know what after
listening to you i'm thinking maybe
that's not so
far fetched well look i mean if you
really think about so
let's talk about gamestop right gamestop
basically had this um
incredible run one of the things that
surprised me was there was no sort of
uh capital markets activity right there
as far as i know there was no debt
issued there was no
uh kind of equity raise at uh even with
the inflated uh
stock price and so that kind of struck
me as like uh maybe a missed opportunity
or maybe there's something i don't know
in terms of why they didn't do it
uh but the second piece of it that i
thought was really interesting
is if you believe the kind of pitch from
the company my understanding is they
want to go from pure
you know product retailer in a physical
presence they want to get more into
gaming
iep they want to have a subscription
product like all that kind of stuff
that's not really that far if you got
people coming into a physical location
you can now say them hey we know you're
into games but you're also very
technical you're also into kind of these
virtual worlds
why don't we sell you some sort of
virtual skin or why don't we sell you
uh you know some sort of uh
cryptocurrency that's inside of a game
right that isn't necessarily a token
uh what happens when all of a sudden you
can take you know a sword that you get
in one game
you can bring it to another world like i
don't know where it goes but that all
feels like that's right up their alley
right that's why this fellow is but you
know very bright guy obviously uh ryan
cullen if he's
i'm sure he's watching him i'm telling
you he's look i love chewie
uh he is the co-500 but that is what i'm
talking you have now put it
far more articulate than i was and have
been but that's what i'm talking about
make the game about you know it make it
a contest make there be
e-gaming and the winners are paid in a
currency that
you and i trust oh you know world wide
currents
deal with worldwide games and i don't
want to
mess with dollars i need something that
can store value
it's fairly funny when you look at you
know i remember once when i was taking
economics class
at college they said listen you know all
you have to do is every seven years you
know that
your money's cut in half with the dollar
i mean so like why do i sit here and
just say you know what i'll just accept
that
we would never accept the idea that
every seven years a car is worthless
or it's it's going it's depreciated
fifty percent or have it a home oh in
seven years you gotta throw that home
away i'm
supposed to be our principal asset and
so all of these things are made of
someone like me it's like an upside down
world
but someone who's younger has the
privilege of not having thought
about the way that we've been stuck with
which brings me to
all of the newfound talk about buying
thing you know
art with tokens and doing what musk is
doing uh
getting uh a discussion going that
frankly is happening so quickly i need
your help i just need your help
what questions do you have about nfts
okay so
why do i when i think about nfts why why
do people talk about uh expensive
sneakers
and a hard to value our why are those
the things that people vote
so let's remember what drives a lot of
value what drives the value of bitcoin
scarcity right it's 21 million of them
what drives the traditional art market
scarcity
what drives the supremes and sneakers
and kind of all of that
uh economy and culture scarcity what
drives trading cards
scarcity now when you get into the
digital world the best way i know how to
explain it is
let's say i have a music file right and
you want to listen to the same song that
i have
uh i say okay great jim i'm gonna send
it to you and i hit send
and in a generalized way what it does is
it sends you the computer file you now
listen to the music and i listen to
music
we both are happy because we get to
listen to the song uh but i don't know
if you got the original
or the copy of those files and so when
it's music who cares you're listening to
the song almost into the song all
is good but if all of a sudden that
computer file
is supposed to represent or does
represent
money uh some sort of scarce art some
sort of digital good
it's really important that you know you
got the original and you didn't get
the counterfeit and so that's where
ultimately
uh kind of the need for some ability to
understand what the original is in the
digital world comes in
the other way to think about it is and i
forget who thought of this but i thought
it was a really interesting way to look
at it
is a serial number so take the eiffel
tower for example in the physical world
the only eiffel tower that has real
value is eiffel tower number zero
zero one every other eiffel tower after
that has almost no value
and they've replicated it in vegas in
the little trinket that you bring home
and they've even built you know real
life models of it in a computer all this
stuff but
eiffel tower number zero zero one is
really important and we all know where
it is and we can go see it and touch it
in the digital world it's really hard to
do that and so ultimately what these
kind of nfts or or
or digital goods are doing is they're
able to prove that if you create
something
this is the original this is uh you know
number zero zero one
and so ultimately when you can now prove
scarcity in a digital wall what do
people do
they just look and they say okay what's
the old stuff right that had
scarcity as a value driver and now i'm
just going to bring it to the new world
it's kind of the equivalent of like a
newspaper saying oh the internet like
let me just pdf my newspaper
just put it on a web page and like i win
but as we saw with the media companies
that's not all of the value that the
internet provided you couldn't change
the headlines you couldn't
distribute it differently you couldn't
put multimedia all that kind of stuff
and so what i'm really excited about is
like what happens
five ten years from now when people
really understand all of the things that
can happen here
and they start to apply it for new types
of goods right and so
i you know whether it's these um kind of
virtual museums
where you could buy a digital good you
could display it in a virtual museum and
then jim can go in virtual reality and
go actually visit that place
or what happens if all of a sudden now
you look at like the music industry
and or you look at some sort of sports
tickets
those things have a secondary market and
those secondary markets can be really
really high volume
but if i'm a sports team and i sell you
on the primary sale that sports ticket
and you go resell it
i only made money on the primary sale
but now if it's a digital good and i can
actually code into the asset and say hey
every time this trades hands i want ten
percent and i sell it to you i make my
money from the primary sale then you
sell it i get ten percent
that person resells i get ten percent
all of a sudden it becomes a pretty big
revenue stream
i think blockchain to be able to make
that happen that i can keep track of the
revenue stream
exactly it's who owns what when right
right is essentially what ends up
happening and so i think that
you know the key piece for people to
understand is like look bitcoin is going
to be
the global reserve currency it's going
to service that kind of world currency
you talked about
but people are trying to figure out this
technology what else can i add to it
and i think we got to be careful because
just like when there's always this uh
highly innovative disruptive technology
people will take it and they'll use it
for good
and they'll use it for bad right and a
lot of times it's hard to tell who's who
because you got good actors and bad
actors all kind of doing similar things
and so i think we want to encourage the
innovation that occurs the
experimentation but we also want to call
out the people who are just doing cash
grabs or just doing things that
kind of are malicious right so i think
that's where you're seeing a lot in the
community around debate
and kind of controversy it's just like
what is kind of the the things that
people should be doing versus things
that people shouldn't be doing
uh but i think bitcoin obviously has
kind of risen above
everything in terms of market cap and
now you're seeing kind of exploration in
these other areas and some of it will
work and some of it won't
but where are we um serious
and where are we not i mean this is the
musk problem you know every time i
mention bitcoin you know people mention
another
coin i i'm trying to take it as
seriously as possible
and i feel like that uh there are people
who
don't get the seriousness of the topic
or maybe the people who feel like you
know what it must likes it
anything goes i mean where do you come
out on dose
yeah so well here here's the really
really crazy thing right
is i'm a huge believer that like the
meme is the message
and so one of the most effective ways to
communicate with a very large portion of
the internet population today
is via these memes and gifts and all
this stuff and so the easiest
manifestation of that is literally i can
put a picture with some words on it or
whatever and you and i laugh
but you you get the message right it's
kind of like a good joke right there's a
hint of truth and
a great humor to it um but what i think
that we're starting to see is well what
happens when those
memes are financialized so what's the
difference between dogecoin and gamestop
well some people may say nothing other
people will say they're two completely
different things
right but what you're starting to see
again is you're seeing that when you
democratize
access and you start to break down that
walled garden
uh for markets and you say that people
it doesn't matter if you have a lot of
money doesn't matter if you're
you know wear a suit and tie to work
every day anyone in the world with an
internet connection can play the game
you get all kinds of weird stuff right
and some people just say look i like the
stock
right it's uh uh you know roaring kitty
said or
you get elon musk who thinks that
dogecoin he just likes it
okay great right and so he goes and he
tweets about it and so i think we got to
be
um we got to be cautious right we don't
want people to especially with large
audiences to kind of lead folks to the
slaughterhouse but at the same time
there is an element of uh this is
entertainment right and so what's the
difference between going and buying a
lottery ticket or buying dogecoin
i don't really know if there's much
right other than the uh the education or
the state gets paid in the lottery and
then does coin they don't get paid very
much
right but other than that i think that a
lot of this stuff uh it's just pure
entertainment and so you gotta let
people have fun
and uh and at the end of the day uh what
do they say over a long period of time
the market's a weighing machine right
we're gonna end up figuring out what uh
what actually has value and what doesn't
but experimentation is important
what i mean should i be on a stockx
i mean should i be trading sneakers as
part of a an asset quote and
some sort of store value i know
here's what i would say right is if you
look at a traditional 6040 global
portfolio
i literally think you could take your
cash and your bond position and throw it
out the window
and so now you got a bunch of liquidity
right in your portfolio that you say
what do i do with this
and sure you can keep go piling into the
stock market and buying more of the same
assets but you're just getting more and
more concentrated so you want some
diversification
yes i think people are buying some
bitcoin right which obviously you've
started to talk about but i think that
they're also looking for other types of
alternative assets and
uh in some crazy way like you know
timber
used to be this crazy idea like we're
gonna buy
timber and that's an alternative asset
well now that's a pretty well accepted
especially in institutional world like
that is something that people will do
well i actually think that every
institutional investor in one day is
going to be buying alternative assets
but they're going to be buying
sports cards they're going to be buying
sneakers they're going to be buying all
this stuff
because again it all comes back to
scarcity and when
you live in a world where it is
impossible for the federal reserve and
elected officials to stop devaluing the
currency
and they have their hands tied behind
their backs they can't raise interest
rates
you ultimately are going to have this
flight to safety but safety
gets really really big aperture because
people are saying wait a minute
i can't hold just real estate i can't
hold just stocks i got to get other
stuff
and you know look there's all kinds of
crazy stuff people are buying some of it
will be worthless some of it won't be
but i i just think that there's a
generation who they want the sports
cards they want the digital art they
want the sneakers right and so
who who are you and i to say that
they're wrong i don't know
i'm reading the tremendous book called
titan and it's the biography of brock
john d rockefeller
and he was the richest man and he
figured out
that kersey that oil was going to have
tremendous scarcity value
people couldn't even figure out what it
was going to be used for he had already
decided that it was going to have
scarcity value
so he buys every refinery in cleveland
and people don't understand why he's
buying any because it makes no sense
because people can't even envision
well what the hell is he gonna do with
it and then
well what did he did with it was he
cornered basically cornered one of the
most important markets in the world
but right now there'd be you and me with
will rockefeller and flagler which was
his buddy
and they would be talking about the need
to own all the oil in the world
because there's only so much oil and
other guys would just say here here take
my oil for a hundred thousand
and it was worth a hundred million but
they should take a product that
sometimes i feel like bitcoin take it
for six thousand i am so thrilled to get
rid of it
all the people who sold the refineries
for a hundred thousand thought they did
great
they all thought they did great they
would be names on buildings and
hospitals and schools
but no they thought they did great and
they thought they did great because
they did not have the creativity that
you had to take a look or what
rockefeller had
to realize you know what this thing may
have tremendous tremendous value
and a lot of people laughed at
rockefeller he was a kind of a cranky
guy
but he had a vision and it was a vision
that this stuff that was in a western
part of pennsylvania where no one was
willing to go
it was worth a great deal and you know
you and i are talking about this
and i do feel like it's cleveland right
after they decided you know what maybe
it can light
maybe it can be used to light things up
they hadn't thought about anything else
and imagine maybe we are like you talked
about maybe we're going to be in a
virtual room
like uh like jensen juan has told me at
nvidia listen jim one day maybe you go
into room and you're alone but you want
to talk to five people who
love mozart boom i'll give you the five
who love mozart
now just like you also said there's
going to be people who use it for evil
we have to be sure that doesn't happen
but right now our minds are our limiting
factor
and i find older minds really have to be
careful because they're the ones that
are good that were ruined in weimar
they were the ones that were ruined in
zimbabwe and when i say
ruined i mean literally they thought
they had a lot of money
and it turned out that they didn't and
it's not necessarily any different for
what you and i are talking about right
now
we all may have fought before the
government prints four trillion dollars
then we had a lot of money but maybe we
don't and we don't have oil
but we can buy if you're at square i
mean i i am
most appreciative of anyone who watches
this and says well listen
i see bitcoin at x but i can go into
square of my cash app
and i can buy some put some every a
month every month put some away
i think you'd probably be appreciative
for someone trying to do that
absolutely so you bring up john
rockefeller and
one of my favorite stories about him is
obviously he gets in a uh
a little um you know uh issue with uh a
lot of the guys who run the railroads
and uh what what is probably one of the
smartest things that he ever did was
then he said well i'm just gonna use
a a pipeline i'm gonna literally create
pipelines i'm going to
push the oil there and i'm going to go
around your railroads and you can kick
rocks so i think that
i guess yeah in innovators
screw you absolutely so innovators
innovate but
here's an idea for you that i think the
world hasn't yet woken up to
that uh when i sit back and i say you
know what's a secret that investors if
they start to wrap their head around
this we'll start to change the way they
invest
is uh we talk a lot about commodities
right let's talk about oil and all kinds
of other commodities but
actually the world's most valuable
commodity right
and if you go back to cleveland and
people realizing that this kerosene and
oil was going to be so
valuable before everybody else's
computing power
is the world's most valuable commodity
and so ultimately what bitcoin is backed
by
is the world's strongest computing
network right it is backed by
the strongest commodity in the world
it's the largest
kind of computing network commodity in
the world and so i think that what we're
starting to see
and it's starting early where there's
still a lot of people drop their head
around this
is if you start to think of computing
power as a commodity
and then you start to say to yourself
well who owns the pipes
to the computing power well jeff bezos
and aws is doing pretty well
yeah the bitcoin network is backed by
the strongest computing network in the
world
it's a trillion dollar asset now right
and so you start to start to look around
and say
where's the computing power right where
is that pointed to
who's providing it who's the underlying
infrastructure that's making that
possible
i think that that whole world and that
whole economy and industry is going to
get really really interesting
pipes but but there's another piece of
it that gets me even more excited which
is
um if you look at some of these
companies like great american mining and
there's a whole slew of them
what they're doing is they're saying
we're going to connect that old
commodity world to the new
uh commodity world so they go out to the
oil and gas guys they say hey
you guys are killing the environment you
guys are flaring all this gas out here
and it's one of the most harmful things
you can do but you're doing it because
you found oil
what if we could actually capture the
flare gas and we could turn it into
power
on site and we could mine bitcoin right
here whoa
and that's what they're doing is they're
literally powering bitcoin mining
uh equipment on site at the oil and gas
uh kind of uh
wellhead and they're capturing flare gas
and they're mining
because all you have to do is have an
internet connection in these machines
all right that's the way it's i just
stopped yourself
all right so i'm meeting with the ceo
coca-cola
and i said how much you pay for the
carbon dioxide he tells me price i said
i gotta get
why don't we take all the carbon dioxide
that comes out of the wells
when they drill and we'll send it to
coca-cola here's the way i'm thinking
i'm thinking about a soft drink you're
thinking about bitcoin
and that is the difference but you see
after this interchange
i know enough with with the co2 and the
coca-cola
you've got an idea that is brilliant
every kind of thing in woods tomorrow
and exxon i'm gonna say what the hell
why why can't you diversify like this
every company
every single company in the world that
has any sort of power generation
is going to do this because the
financial incentive is
way too high every day right now bitcoin
miners are paid like 50 to 55 million
dollars all around the world every day
so we're talking about you know billions
and billions of dollars in terms of
annual revenue to bitcoin miners right
but the beauty is that you don't have to
go buy
equity in a minor to get that exposure
exxon said hey you know what we got a
lot of gas flaring going on we got a lot
of access to power
why don't we just buy some of these
computers plug them in and then we'll
start to get our own fair share
of that revenue you would see that not
only
are these companies going to have what a
lot of people are referring to like a
michael saylor referred to as a treasury
strategy
how do how do i go ahead and buy bitcoin
and put it on my balance sheet and kind
of use that to protect my shareholder
value
but also what they're going to start to
say is wait a second i need a p
l strategy how do i actually participate
in this economy and drive
revenue and profits off of this and so i
think that ultimately
the financial incentive for this system
is going to be incredible
it's just that people are uneducated yet
they haven't spent the time or if you're
running an exxon
this last thing in your mind is how do i
mind it over time though that changes
like rockefeller
you just got to think like rockefeller
who was this bumpkin
but he had thoughts like this he if he
were he wouldn't be rolling over his
grave right now he would be saying you
know what
i want to go right now and ring the neck
of the exxon guy that he hasn't thought
about it or
worse that he thinks it's small of
course
that's what the people felt were the
refineries the 27 clever fighters
they thought they were small but when
you took them together oh my god
well anyway look i gotta go shoot i
gotta go like oh man i gotta go lose
money versus make money
you are pure joy let me ask let me ask
you one question before i let you go
sure what is what has been uh we talked
last uh i think at q4 last year so we're
uh almost three months into uh 2021
what's been the biggest surprise in the
financial markets for you
i think that the bigger the biggest
surprise
is a belief uh that could actually turn
out to be
true that the companies that we
um that 20
that the second half of 20 and this
could be tough
for jay pal that the second half of 2021
could be
like 19 like 1990. i mean not even
not even better than 46 okay even better
than 46
or if you go read grant another great
book
1866 where there was this
sudden you know 500 000 of our guys
remember much smaller country died
no one's able to do anything and then
suddenly 1866 occurs
and people don't even like nothing's
happened in the country for six years
and then bingo everything happens and
i think that to bring it full sprayer
with bitcoin
if you believe and you have taught me
that my boom thesis is true
if you are not hedged against what a
booming mean in this country
you're nuts i mean literally you're nuts
if my thesis is right on a boom you're
crazy not that bitcoin
and i don't care i don't care if it's 70
000 right now
i'd be saying the same thing i wouldn't
be saying and you got to wait for a pull
back to 53 000
but now you say listen if my thesis is
true and i've spent a lot of time on my
thesis
the only way that you can protect your
assets is going to
you can obviously buy certain stocks but
i'm talking about protecting your assets
insurance the way i like insurance and i
buy insurance
is with bitcoin pump i don't know what
else to do
the boom means bitcoin i
uh i will leave it at that because i
definitely agree with you and i think
that people are drastically
underestimating what we're about to uh
witness and uh
you you and i will talk later this year
and i think we will be happy we're gonna
talk sooner than that because it's too
much fun
thank you again it's very rare that you
ever in life get to say
listen i owe you one and i owe you one
big partner all righty
all right jim thank you so much we'll do
it again thank you pop appreciate